I get to keep up with my kids all summer in these halal shorts because,
like, they're double shorts.
There's deep pockets on this inner shorts that's, like,
tight and fit to your body so nothing's gonna be falling out.
They have a tight,
stretchy waistband, and you feel like you're, like,
keeping up with all the, like,
preppy little sporty moms that are out there like,
oh, yeah, you know,
I have my cute little preppy shorts, too.
It keeps you secure,
but they're loose and flowy at the same time,
so it keeps you covered,
you know, you don't have to be embarrassed.
And there's such a lightweight material just like Halara always makes.
These are absolutely comfortable.
Absolutely a summer must have.
You get up to 30% off if your first time user of the TikTok Shop.
It is linked right here.
I am 5 9 and 165 pounds.
There's free shipping and free returns if for some reason
you're not happy.
But I think you're gonna absolutely love them.